Hello,
and welcome to Clustered.
Today is episode 16 of Clustered, and we
will be fixing some rather broken Kubernetes clusters
by two fantastic guests.
Before we get started, there's just a little
bit of housekeeping.
If you're not already a subscriber, you should
do so now. Click that subscribe button, tick
the bell, get notifications for all new episodes
from the Rawkode Academy.
My goal is to provide the best cloud
native and Kubernetes learning materials for us all
to learn this fast landscape together. So we'd
like you to join us.
Also, if you wanna chat with other cloud
native and Kubernetes people, you can join us
on the Discord server available at Rawkode.chat.
I also wanna thank Teleport who started sponsoring
Clustered a few weeks ago. We've been using
Teleport since the very first episode of Clustered.
It is a fantastic tool, and I really
appreciate their support.
I won't give you the pitch for the
product. You'll see it for yourself as we
fix a couple of clusters in just a
moment.
Now today's clusters are broken by. Like I
said, two fantastic guests, and I'm gonna bring
them in.
Now here we are. Hello, Andy. Hello, Rachel.
How are you both today?
Doing well. Thank you.
Good. Thanks. Awesome. Well, thank you so much
for joining me. Can we just start with
a quick round of introductions? I'll just say,
Andy, first, since you're right next to me
on the screen, and then Rachel, please tell
us a little bit about yourselves.
Yeah. So I guess I started doing Kubernetes,
bare metal on prem,
and, like, Chef
on one dot nine,
and then just kind of progressing the automation
from
Chef through
cluster API,
change gears, and now doing it for Equinix
metal on lighting up dark data centers
with a global Pixie Boot and Flat Car.
So
Nice. Thank you.
And, Rachel?
Yep. I'm Rachel Leakin. I'm a solution architect
at VMware helping customers modernize their applications onto
Kubernetes.
I started in Kubernetes probably now three years,
more on the architect side,
and then started to get down into the
weeds when I joined the VMware
and helping customers set up their clusters. Now
I'm already helping them get their applications onto
clusters.
A side note from that, outside, I'm a
big Chelsea fan, as you can see.
I had to you know, since we're light
slight competition, I had to, you know, represent
my team, champions of Europe, so
a little bit about me. Alright.
Thank you both very I'm just gonna share
something from the audience because I think it's
really funny. But just before we went live,
Rachel was informing us that you made two
extra breaks to the cluster, which, of course,
is wonderful.
And I I I mentioned that a lot
of breakers do that because they panicked of
not broken enough or they've taken it too
far, and then Andy made best face. So
we've got two potentially disastrous clusters,
and I think we should jump straight into
our first one and see what we can
fix. So
our first cluster today is
rituals,
which means, Andy, you and I are up
first.
Okay.
I am gonna click connect. Oh, my computer
decides to play. There we go. I'm gonna
click connect on the control plane node of
our first cluster. I'm gonna remove that teleport.
Thank you.
Andy, if you can do me a favor
and join a session and just type echo
hello or whatever you want so that I
know you're here.
Wow. Straight for the VIM and the batch
RC.
Alright. There we go.
And the first thing we normally do here
is export our cube config and check for
a control plane. I will let you do
that with whichever means you wish.
Yeah.
Sorry. I'm used to being quiet while I
sit on incident calls.
Well, that's a good start. We got a
server version.
And the git treat is clean.
Alright.
What you wanna do next? I guess we
should check our pods. We
got some pending pods. Alright.
What do you wanna do first?
Let's look at the cute system.
Looks like
pod network is a little borked.
Well, yeah, I see two terminating core DNS,
two pending,
some broken ciliums.
Yeah. Quite a lot broken. Do
you want to
should we describe something and see if we
can get some better messages?
I think we should take a look at
the
the not ready Cilia logs.
Okay.
it's a common port.
I see it all the time. What is
that?
That is one of the API server ports.
I'm assuming our
node to node networking is
working.
Nice alias. I like that.
Yeah. I believe I got that from mister
Brent Buckley in the chat when we were
at SendGrid together.
Well, it looks like the scheduler was bounced
recently.
Well, that's different.
No. They've I think they probably have changed
how describe works
because I know that used to work.
You spelled system wrong in your alias.
Okay.
At least that's an easy fix.
Our colleague, our joint colleague, Zoe is laughing
at your thinking face.
Oh, would you look at that?
Images.
It looks like the official image.
What were you checking for there?
Well, I noticed that the scheduler
was bounced fourteen hours ago,
So I assume that that bounced because Rachel
did something.
I did something, but I didn't know that's
what I was doing.
And then for people who don't know, the
caret
word caret is said in your last history
entry.
Okay. So queue, it seems back. Running. Yeah.
Scheduling disabled on both the worker nodes.
You think that's just a card in?
Yeah. I mean, to put that in the
status is typically what that would mean.
Okay.
Creating container.
Ambassador's
coming up.
Looks like came
up.
I'm guessing we have to hop on to
the other two nodes and enable
Cubelet.
Why did you think that? Sorry.
These are still stuck in
creating.
In my iTerm having highlights is always fun.
Well, it's it's also in
iTerm. When you highlight something, it automatically goes
to your paste buffer.
Ah, of course.
So
I mean, it looks like it's pulling the
image.
Yeah. Looks like an official Postgres image.
Which means we do have a cubelet.
Would you like me to open up a
shell on one of those nodes?
Oh, there they go.
And you were just being impatient.
I would never do such a thing.
Are we supposed to have three Postgres?
Nope.
Although I don't think it matters, to be
fair.
They don't use any volumes. Sorry,
Rachel? I was just trying to deflect, you
know, just, you know, because I
was being I was putting on my developer
hat. I was like, why do we just
have one? That doesn't, you know, make sense.
So
And this is not a problem, though. Like
I said, there there's no volumes. They load
everything via an an a container into the
database.
Yeah. Except then the traffic's going to get
split by Cilium to three different pods.
And if they're not set up in a
Replica
master
whole
shindig, it's potentially
not going to render correctly.
I assume cluster talks to it. I actually
didn't spend any time looking at your application.
Root?
So clustered speaks to each Postgres. They're not
clustered. Like I said, the data is also
static, so you could have 50,000 Postgres. It
would be alright.
But, yeah, Brett, we can clean it up
over here.
No ingresses.
There's no ingress, but we do use the
teleport proxy feature. So if I jump along
here and click applications,
we should be able to click clustered.
Give it a few seconds while it does
the proxy magic,
and we have an internal server error on
our application.
Oh,
our cluster Yes.
Sorry?
I broke it correctly.
I I will point out that
this is not my application report in this
internal server error, I don't think. So we've
got some work to do.
I was hoping you were being nice to
us, Rachel, and it was just a cubelet
in the scheduler.
Is that not is that not it?
That was the the basis for it. And
then I was like, that's not enough. I
gotta, like, break some more things, slight things.
So that image is correct. G h c
r. So it's got a container registry,
Rawkode cluster, good one.
Image,
container port.
Looks good. That's a problem.
What's
the problem?
The limit?
Yeah. It's only getting one millisecond of CPU
time per second.
So
right. So that would cause basically constant throttling
because I'm not even sure how many I
don't think one is a appropriate value for
CPU. It would need to be Yeah. No.
It can be a string or an integer.
But one would that be a core or
one melee core?
One core.
So the suffix
oh, chat's telling me I missed something in
memory.
No. One twenty eight, assume, would be fine.
So what's the deal with if you set
CPU to one without the m prefix, it
just defaults to?
One's one vCPU.
Yeah. Right. Okay. So
that's something that the cube community spent a
lot of time centralizing. So if you're in
vSphere, AWS, Azure, or on bare metal, it
guarantees you roughly the same amount
of compute time. And so the way to
reach us the an integer one would be,
like, one second of compute time per one
second of human time.
Okay. Got it.
See if that redeployed.
Do you wanna try to hit the service
again?
I'd love to. Let's see. It
could be cached, but let me it
is still broken.
Okay.
Yeah. So the average load looks fine, so
I don't think we're getting CPU pegged.
Let's see.
If she did that in one place, she
may have done it in another.
Let me go through my bash history to
see if I can find a useful j
q command.
So, basically, what I wanna do is just
go through all the containers
and look for,
their resources and limits. Like, you can just
do quick control edit
pod, and it'll give you all of them.
As a single document with them.
Yes.
Or
I'm learning some new commands over here. Nice.
Or like that.
So let's see. One
one
Looks good. 200 probably fine. Onset. Onset.
This is core DNS because they are so
particular about the amount of RAM they use.
What? A 70?
Yeah. They are insistent that that is enough
for every pod you could possibly ever need.
There you go.
Okay. So
yep. So we've got our pod running. But
when we try to browse through it through
Teleport,
we get an internal server error. Now how
does Teleport work?
So we expose
the the service as a node port service
on the node, and teleport is proxying through
that node port service.
So if you do that yep. There we
go. You should see we have
a
Well, those don't have IPs.
Yes. And it looks like our
clustered service
has been either modified, deleted, or something else
created.
In fact, it was my cluster service, doesn't
mean the load balancer.
I think the other hint is the age
on it.
External traffic policy
won't apply to node ports.
How do I wanna do this?
If this yells at me, I'm just deleting
it.
You could probably set that to node port.
And
I think the first five lines of that
spec can be deleted and inferred on the
next creation.
The traffic policy should only matter if,
like, Matt Anderson applied more cluster network policies.
Speaking of,
I might have done a lot of research,
and
that episode was brutal.
So their network policies can trip you up.
That's for sure. I have no idea about
the silly and post network policies.
Those are dangerous.
Okay.
Does ambassador need to be fixed? No.
Ambassador
does not need to be fixed.
Okay.
Do you wanna try to load the
application?
Yeah. I still don't think it'll work because
of the cluster IPs in that surface.
So do you mind if I type?
Yeah. Go for it.
You're, like, right there, Andy. You're, like
you're you're you're right there.
I think we can just remove
all of these. I don't think that they're
Okay. Doing anything for us.
And I don't even remember if that's the
correct node port. So I may have to
check our teleport config.
Node port complaining
you? Actually, I was going to just delete
it and recreate it through K Expose.
It's not letting me delete those anyway. So
what was I complaining about? What was that?
Okay.
Yeah. Let's check the port. 31644.
As 30,000,
there's a node port we expect.
You guys are so logical with this. I
was just, like, really breaking it like it's
a. I don't
know anything about Kubernetes,
so I'm just gonna break everything. I I
want my app to work or not work.
I really put on my developer hat.
I've never touched Kubernetes and just
broke it.
Alright. It's still
not working.
Alright. Click on it. So
So one useful command is the explain command.
It's kinda like having built in docs.
So Do you want to do it on
a shared buffer?
Yeah.
The explain command is cool.
Yeah. If people don't know about this,
you can basically give it a path in
the spec
of the object,
and it explains it.
So
that being said,
Rachel did create the service, so I'm highly
inclined to just delete the service.
Okay.
You can always reapply it from source, I
guess.
Yeah.
Where's the source at?
Is it here? Rawkode
Cluster. Oh, hold on.
What's that?
Did you make that file?
No.
Oh, it's is that UTC?
That's probably UTC, isn't it?
Yeah.
Yeah. That looks like a backup.
It does look like a backup. Your magic
key. That looks like their secret
Easter egg in there. Was trying to hide
for you.
Alright.
We're getting the
watch, which means we can try and upgrade
our application from v one to v two
and see if we get the happy then.
How many bogamips do these computers have?
Oh,
wow. That's a lot.
These are our c one smalls
on Equinix metal.
Okay. Yeah. So I think they're maybe 32
cores, 16 gig of RAM, or 32 gig
of RAM and 16 cores. Don't remember.
There's eight CPUs.
Why? Why? If I had to build a
service, I might do it on Equinix metal
myself.
It
is nice having access to the metal. I've
gotta see.
Let's test our application.
I think I still have the watch, isn't
it? Yeah. Let's refresh.
One browser. Pull the new one.
I
don't know if that updated
yet.
Looks like it's up.
Oh, there we go.
Alright.
We have the dance.
Alright. Good job, Andy. Thank you, Rachel.
Maybe it wasn't that bad. I gave you
that hint.
I wrote some other things, but they they
were all more distractions
than
actually breaking it, as you can see.
Well, other things were were hiding for us
if we managed to accidentally pick them up.
Yeah.
Noel got one. I, you know, changed some
port protocols and just little things, port values,
just in other places
just to distract you guys.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you very much.
Cool. Cool. Alright. Let's jump over.
Let's swap places.
Clustered.
Pull up Andy's.
Maybe.
Alright.
Alright. I'll just tape it in.
Okay.
I I have teleport running with Andy's cluster.
I will click connect and open the control
plane node. Rachel, if you can get logged
in, join a session, give me an echo,
let me know that you're here.
Andy, feel free to have a laugh.
There's no ever on the road. I'm
gonna be laughing at myself.
So
Awesome.
Okay. So step one is typically to export
a cube config and check if we have
a control plane. Feel free to do that
however you wish.
Alright. One.
Everything saved.
Let's
see. What's the
I
don't remember the stuff. Admin.com.
Yeah. You got it. Alright.
Let's see. I don't use any alias, so
I'm just lazy, and I never remember anything.
So
oh,
oh, man. Are you killing me already, Andy?
Don't think that's good control. I think Andy's
been cheeky.
Andy,
really? How could you do this to me
already?
I'll be honest. I don't even know. No.
David's right. That is cheeky.
Okay. Okay.
So Let
me see.
Let's just open it then and see what
is left for us.
Okay.
That's
just what are we
we got anything on here? What's this?
I just just see what this is. You're
both just leaving random yeah. Oh, I left
that random layout.
Yeah. Was like, alright. Who do I run
up after myself?
What's
where are we at Yeah.
I think we I don't think that's gonna
be a a binary. I don't know if
you think the same, but maybe we should
just open it and
and see.
Okay. You wanna open the the which binary?
The cube c c l binary. Okay. Let's
say that. I mean, do you expect this
to be a binary or do you think
this is gonna be a bash script that
just prints out a crappy sentence?
I've
never seen anything like this. That's so funny.
I've never got that
message
before when I work
I I think stories. So Oh.
Alright. Okay. So it only does it when
we have a subcommand.
I know. Oh gosh.
Did you break the cluster or did you
break KubeCTL?
Which one did you break?
I don't it's a have you guys ever
had to try to find, like, what messages
are embedded in a binary?
Uh-huh.
What command would you use for that?
So we can use strings on no. No.
It is strings. Right? String. Yeah.
Oh, no.
You might have to install it. Yeah. I
think I need to install maybe
elf utils or estrus.
But I don't think we should
should we just remove cube control and reinstall
it?
I'm trying to see if there's any
hint online
that I'm missing.
What else?
Oh, dependency warnings.
Jeremy says honk.
Need some help, guys. What's this?
Okay.
Should we
look at backup admin config file?
Well, I was hoping we'd have a kib
control
package file liner and which I thought was
in VarCache app, but
does not appear to be there. So I'm
probably just looking at the wrong location.
So
let's see.
Yeah. It doesn't seem to be there. Okay.
So But we could always just curl, download
Kube control from GitHub release and use that.
Unless Andy's trying to tell us or take
us on a journey with his randomly compelled
binary.
Well Can we will say So sometimes the
standard practice is to install stuff under slash
opt
as optional
software for
according to video.
Do not look here.
Okay.
Yeah. Drop in that directory, and we'll take
a look.
Please please respect my privacy.
Oh, I didn't change the path. I just
did it there.
Oh. Sorry. Alright.
Wait. What's the
wait. And what is that? Is that
what is that green represent? I don't know.
Green is executable.
So Oh.
There's
a Linux command we can run.
Type, which will tell you if it's a
binary or script, or we could just open
it in Vim.
I generally just open or fail. Sorry. I
would use the file. Yeah.
You want to Vim?
Yeah. I would just open Vim. Yeah. I
feel like that's unsafe, but I feel like
Alright. Well, we know that we have a
feel like a a credibility, but I hope
it was safe.
So
So I suspect this is either
the
bad binary or maybe it's a backup that's
decoyed as a bad binary and might be
a working cube control.
I don't think it's a bad binary.
Yeah. That I think that's a real cube
control.
Just
protocol.
Okay.
Can
I do
where was that command?
Yeah. Can I export this instead? Is that
what I would do?
Guessing. Well, we could just alias cube control
to slash opt. Do not look here honk,
or we can take the sledgehammer approach and
move honk into user bank cube control.
Let's move it. Let's Yeah. I think that
that was if it's getting caught caught off
under our own feet, I think.
I'm gonna copy
here.
It's just user bank on this machine.
Oh, okay. Yeah.
And,
like, I don't like the word honk, though.
Alright. Just overwrite cube control. Like, whoever that
other cube control is, I don't care.
Okay.
Sledgehammer.
Just smash that thing away.
So we should be able to run a
cube control get pods now.
Oh, yeah. This unsafe directory here.
Alright. Now we have a broken control plan,
which I think we can start to debug.
Okay.
Should I look here?
Let me see. Did you,
did you have in these
in here?
Didn't break anything here.
Where do we start? You say control?
So, I mean, I think the good thing
would be to do an LS minus l
and check the timestamp. Although they mean nothing
there.
People are normally aren't sneaky enough to hate
them.
That
one of them stands out to me that
it may be modified.
Okay. Go.
That was you dipped?
Is that the one that you're suspecting?
No. I think the API server. It was
modified today. Oh,
I'm looking at the wrong date. They all
look like '23. Okay.
Okay.
Let's,
take a look.
And
where's all my comments? Everyone was helping out
Andy. Now everyone's quiet.
I want I want that's just myself now.
I want more because as you could see,
I made mine pretty straightforward.
Alright. I'll talk more. I was No. No.
No. I want the audience to participate. They
were like, comment the lore for Andy. I
don't feel the same love, so it's okay.
It's okay. I'll figure it out. I mean,
one thing is,
how how are static manifests deployed?
How are they deployed? And then is there
any difference here,
David and Teleport? Or it's like So what
we've got here is what looks like a
standard API server so far.
Although,
that's sneaky.
Why
are you deploying your own version of the
API server, Andy?
You're just testing out a new version, a
new feature flag?
Well,
I mean, have you ever like, you wanna
make a change, and then it's just really
hard to deploy that locally
on Docker for desktop.
So oh, sorry. Let me I think we
should do a great
image across all leads.
And we'll see that the standard path or
prefix for control plane components is Kubernetes dot
g c r dot I o. So let's
modify the API server not to use Quito
I o slash a Holzman.
Okay.
I was
gonna look at mine to just take that
one in case anything
it changed even that. I'm not sure anymore.
That's the joy of clustered. It plays tricks
on your minds.
Yeah. I'm like, let me just go to
make sure.
Let me take I'm gonna just look at
mine real quickly. My
eyes so my eyes are not deceiving me.
I'll just check if there's any other red
headings on this file before I replace the
image.
Oh, there's not.
Oh, that was very kind of you to
tell us.
Yeah.
Oh, wait a second. What is he using
21.one?
Is that what he has there?
No. I thought it was 20 1 2.
Was I think it's Yeah. Yeah.
It is. It's right. Okay. Just making sure
that he didn't switch one number on this.
Well, I thought about running the 20
The 1 20 2 R c.
But
What? Just deprecate all the ingress and mutate
and webhook namespaces there. That would be nice.
Pull out the pods to get this back.
Rachel, do you wanna try
control playing command again, like, pods or something
and see
if it's a simple thing?
No. Yeah. It doesn't Oh, we get it
just one more time.
It's Oh, no. That's That is correct. You
you restore that file.
So the kubelet is responsible for running this.
So we should check the kubelet is running.
Anywhere
else in here before we
I I I I don't think so. I
would try
system control states kubelet.
Alright. Create system
control.
What's
what's
it? Kubelet? It's system control status, kubelet.
I think Naveen is sorry. Naveen is trying
to be helpful.
Oh.
Yeah. We could check the admin config. We
could have modified that, but we also do
have Kubelet errors here.
Control play. Mhmm. K.
We'll have service.
Okay.
So
So our Kiplit is
running.
So we probably wanna check that the API
server has been restarted.
But I would just use
PS with your favorite arguments if you have
any.
I I don't I I don't really go
into this to this level of depth, so
I just gotta, like I have to look
it up every single time, but okay. Sorry.
Okay. So I like AUX. Just don't ask
me what they mean. I just they're just
ingrained now in my memory. But it doesn't
look like we have an API server running
even though we do have a kubelet running.
So the container logs,
11 file log
containers,
And I suspect
oh, we're not getting anything here either.
That's tricky.
That is interesting.
So that means one of two things in
my head.
Either he's modified where static manifest is supposed
to live and our change was ignored.
Mhmm.
Be.
You gonna say something?
Oh, I I was
Go ahead, Andy.
I'll
be honest. I'm surprised as you are that
there's no logs there. Alright. Okay. So you
haven't changed the static manifest.
Alright.
I'm gonna restart the Kubelet, which has always
caused me problems in the past. But you
know what? Doesn't matter. Let's do it. Do
we wanna
check the admin config file as well afterwards?
Yeah. I think that's a good idea too.
I'm just
there we go. That seems to be doing
stuff now. So not I mean, not good
stuff because we've got error messages, but
we have stuff.
Do we have any APIs? No. We don't.
And we don't have any logs from our
API server. What have you done, Andy?
Remember that face I made? I
if you might might have felt like mind
games, but we're at we're at the same
point at this at right at this juncture.
So this is unexpected behavior?
Yeah. Yes. Oh, wonderful. Alright.
Alright. We gotta get her thinking out, Sonia,
Rachel.
Okay.
Well, if
okay. Let's let's
let's go back real quick and just look
at the config files as well. Get through
those out. Yeah. Yeah. That's really
I don't know why I'm I'm gonna refresh
my tab as well. Go. We choose to
You want me to wait? There we go.
No. It's okay. Go for it. Okay.
So But
I think that only thing I'd really be
interested in here is that server URL,
which I think is okay.
At least the I think so too. Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay. Let's I'm gonna think aloud because I'm
I'm not sure what our next step is.
So the kubel is responsible for starting all
of our containers.
We're not even seeing any log output from
the API server, which makes me think
the kubelet either can't speak to container d
or container d just doesn't do what we
want it to do.
So I think we should check the status
of container d using system control.
That's kinda where my head's at.
Okay.
I'd also like to point out I already
set the,
runtime socket for you because you have a
slight kind
even though I don't like it right now.
Unity
responded
and it running.
There was an error message there though.
Oh,
I couldn't pull the image.
Did I mess that up?
It looks
like the same one that I had.
Oh, look at that. It's in TLS header.
I must have messed up the path. Right?
I didn't.
No. It looks as if it looks
same of what I had.
Are
we really unfortunate and GCR is having problems?
I don't think so. I'll check from my
side.
What's the
a container d command CTR
image pool.
Let's just try Docker IO engine next first.
That just c t r pool. I can't
remember.
Hey. Chat help us out. C r I
cuddle pool.
Oh, c r I cuddle. Control.
Okay.
Yeah. That pulls an image.
So container config file?
Where is that? Maybe it's not pulling an
image.
I see
nothing on my screen.
Okay. So there's a really cool container d
command
called config
dump.
We don't have a container d command. That's
really interesting.
I
I don't think I've ever had it do
that before.
Okay.
So we can take a look at the
the drop ins for container d.
Have you used container d's plugin alias feature
to move the GCI repository
just before I start getting down the wrong
path?
No. I that that that's already been done.
I tried to avoid prior art.
Okay. Then I'm really confused
about
this.
K. So That should work.
What's that?
Did you there's something you broke with the
teleport?
No.
That only broke on the worker notes,
but I fixed it.
Because I tried to follow the rules of
engagement,
which made out my own issues.
I we are in this together now. I'm
just being quiet. I'm gonna try and pull
this from my local machine
before
I start debugging the wrong thing because
Might I recommend not pulling the one I
created?
Yeah. I went to that. Alright.
Here is my terminal.
Oh, I don't even have Docker open.
Docker
image.
Oh,
and give docker a few minutes to start.
Yeah. And we can't pull the API server
image.
We may have to just use Andy's API
server. Is it fixable?
Oh, I wouldn't do that.
It's not going here. So okay. So we're
getting TLS errors. Right? What are the things
that can lead to Are those expected? I
thought those were unexpected errors.
Sort of, but they're related to other errors
I Right. Okay. I'll be on it. I
have to stop my break when this broke
too much.
Okay. Well, as there as those two last
errors are expected, then, okay, we can debug
that. I thought it was an external factor.
So
What about our
should we hop on the
the worker node and check
our certs or something on there?
So if we can't fill the image on
this control point node,
then
I feel like
I'm gonna get this wrong so
someone can try and correct me. But
there is a certificates package from Ubuntu which
installs all of the root c s that
we can trust.
Yep.
Now if those
oh, sorry.
We can maybe just reinstall that package
and see if that fixes it and failing
that we may need to dig into a
little bit deeper.
So there is a
at spell
c a dash certificates.
C a cert is that it? Okay. Yeah.
I had to put it in the container
I built.
And
we can do
does that work? Oh, that's interesting.
Yeah.
Ah, there we go.
Ah, so you have broken
more things.
This was not an intentional break.
Yeah.
Alright. We have no networking.
Oh, we have limited networking because Teleport's working.
But
Mhmm.
I don't suppose you're a networking expert, Rachel.
Nope. Neither am I. Perfect.
So Okay.
Okay.
No.
Nolan chat suggested that it could be DNS,
but we couldn't ping eight dot eight dot
eight dot eight.
And in fact, we can't even do an
IP tables dash l.
But Cillium doesn't use IP tables.
You better not have any BPF probe on
my machine.
What did you do, Andy? Oh, man.
Taking a whole
So now I'm just scanning the process tail
to see if I can see anything that
I don't expect to be on this machine
that would be running the eBPF probe.
If it's Cillium,
we'd maybe have to kill Cilium.
I
couldn't tell you what that's gonna do.
Okay. So let me
I think Andy has deployed
some sort of silly and traffic policy
to the cluster, then broken the control plane,
removing our ability to remove such dodgy
policy.
Is that close?
No?
So
that's actually a really good theory about what
probably happened.
However, I will say that this break got
away from me. And when you hit the
app install,
we are now at the same point in
trying to fix this cluster,
which
is otherwise to say, I'm not entirely sure
this is recoverable without, like, a cube ADM
reset.
Well, it will be recoverable. Right? So what
can we do here?
We
have
Russell has a good suggestion.
I don't
know what my from
a command
line is very, very pure.
Is that a command or is that a
process?
Okay.
Let's see what that does. I'm gonna go
out and let them here. So I think
Cillium is responsible for the BPF. I don't
think you compelled John Bennery and ran it
on the machine because I didn't see anything
that looked particularly bad,
which means
I'm gonna kill the Cillium pod.
Okay.
We should Cilium was the part where I
wanted to break.
So that is a good
so I did
set Cilium into a crash loop back off
before I toyed with the API server.
Okay.
Now
it's running.
Okay. So Russell suggest yeah. BPF filter is
a running process,
and those
are
normal. They're
kernel processes,
I think. I don't wanna go destroying it
because I don't think removing the probe would
block the traffic.
I think Celine would need to exit.
One way to find out.
Let's stop the cueplet first.
Okay.
Let's grab
our Cillium.
We don't have a Cilium.
It was in a crash loop.
And then the API server went down, so
there was nothing telling Cubelet to try to
redeploy it. But I have a pod running.
It doesn't mean there's any container. So okay.
Alright. We actually don't have Cilium.
Wow. This cluster is screwed.
Okay. So how do we get so We
could re reboot the machine with the kubelet
disabled, which would get his networking back.
That's the step I do. But as punishment
for doing this, Andy would have to tell
jokes and entertain the audience until the bare
metal machine
rebooted.
So Hey. Luckily, it's a c one small.
These things boot fast.
Alright. Actually, I can tell the story of
my initial break
break, and maybe that can help us figure
out what went wrong with what I did.
Alright. So I've disabled the kiplet. I'm gonna
reboot. You happy with that plan?
Nope.
If it was me, it would've just been
destroyed already, the cluster, but that's just me.
I would've been like, let's just spin up
a new one. Yeah. This stuff. You've got
all that VMware power.
It's easy to do that. Yep. Alright. I'm
rebooting it. Let's go for it.
So We've disabled the cubelet, which should give
us an opportunity to make sure networking and
image builds work before we start it back
up again. But do wanna tell us a
story then?
So I wanted to approach this with a,
like, a a teachable moment and issues that
I've come up to in production.
And one of the most frustrating ones is
when there's a disk error and the Linux
kernel decides to remount the file system as
read only.
Now inducing a disk error is actually really
difficult,
but there's a way to send a message
to the kernel
to tell it make the file system read
only,
except it's a sledgehammer. It should only be
used in kernel development,
and then I did it. And then I
tried to connect the teleport, and the teleport
broke.
So I undid it
because what I wanted to do is I
wanted to, without breaking all the process,
render
etcd in a read only state.
However,
that was only a part of it.
The next thing I wanted to do was
when you fixed the etcd issue,
there would Cilium would come back,
and it would notice that I changed the
pod IP spaces. So I would have reassigned
the pod signer per node,
and each node didn't read only.
So then it tries to recreate all the
pods, they get stuck not being able to
create the the sandbox,
and
you have to go figure out why those
nodes are stuck.
But
that wasn't going to work
because
it broke Teleport, and I want to follow
the rules of engagement.
So
it's alright if I screen share.
Yeah. Go for it if you want.
Noel has kindly pointed out in the chat
that this is the first ever reboot
on clustered,
which is true. Right.
Well, what happens when I click this button?
Oh, I need to So he's, like, poor
cluster.
What did you do to this poor cluster?
What did you do to me, Andy? What
did I I gave you something real I
gave you some, like
you gotta reboot the whole thing.
Oh, no. I'm going to have to,
will the link you sent me work to
rejoin?
Because Yes. But if you're on a Mac
and there's permissions, you can just enable the
permissions. You don't actually need to restart your
browser.
Okay. So later.
Share.
Is it working? Yep. Zoe, he he wait.
Yes.
It is.
So
what I did was I had an idea
for creating a read only API server
that when you make a request to write
something,
it would,
silently
delete the key you just wrote
and then tell you it succeeded from this
transaction.
Hold on. Hold on.
Oh, no. I'm sorry.
I just wanted to do this.
And
so
Can you zoom in on the header?
Yes.
I think.
There we go.
Right. So what I did is I gave
it some time to settle after the API
server comes up, and then it would delete
every key.
So that way, when you try to change
the deployment, it would delete the deployment.
And I had verified that working
on
local Kubernetes cluster I spun up.
And so when I went to move it
over, what I needed to do was retag
the image and push it to a local
Docker registry running on the host.
However, this thing happened
where
I it took more than fifteen minutes to
figure out how to do that with c
r CRI CTL
because that's not a feature it has.
So
then I went to go install Docker,
and Docker wouldn't install because it couldn't resolve
the Ubuntu things. And that's when I realized
how badly I have broken this cluster.
And so I have this concern
that Kubelet
triggered a delete of the master node,
and it's struggling to reregister itself for some
reason.
Alright.
So that's kind of my working theory.
Because what I was going to do and
something I had verified
was
while working was I could
delete
or with Docker d, I was able to
change Etsy host to kates dot g c
r dot I o and pull my malicious
image
and make it look like
the real image.
And the breadcrumb there would be if you
did a version,
it would have told you the git tree
was dirty.
Or if you checked
version on the binary itself in the container
or if you looked at the binary and
you realized it was, like, over a gig.
So there were a couple of breadcrumbs.
Because what I wanted to highlight is that
Docker d at least doesn't support HSTS,
so man in the middle DNS attacks are
totally possible for injecting malicious images if you
want
with kind of so kind of two things.
One,
a read only server can create a bad
day. Two,
DNS attacks
really suck.
And so I'm not sure why HTTPS
isn't working
on container d because I don't think they
support HSTS either. So they're not insisting on
HTTPS.
It's just not able to dial out,
I think, is that error.
So if networking comes back, you might be
onto something. If so far, we we don't
have a bare metal machine yet.
Alright. Let's I'm gonna go to my Equinix
console and see where we are in the
transcript.
You may have clustered our first cluster as
well.
I was asked to break it, and I
almost for a new cluster because I I
thought I broke it too much.
Yeah. We said break it, not destroy
it.
Get all the earth. You know?
Yeah. So silly me for having a rule
that the only thing you don't need to
do is break teleport, which you didn't
ish.
K.
I you're gonna look at the That's cool,
Andy. I mean
Okay. So I've got my screen share back.
What we can see here is I I
can actually SSH on. There's a starting point.
Let me drag that up. I don't think
we have teleport quite yet. I'm not sure
if it's crawling.
No. I can't I can't get in there
yet.
Okay. So let's save teleport.
What
have I got running?
Oh, Docker.
This is why we don't need Docker running.
Oh,
that
fake cube cuddle binary.
All it did was exec the real cube
cuddle binary and then randomly print honk or
make it a rainbow printout.
So it was just there as a little
bit of mental warfare
to because it it literally just execs that
binary
with the args and then pipes the the
information back. So that was supposed to be
fun,
except I broke it too much, and you
just saw the error message in rainbow print.
Okay. So
here's where we are. We have the machine.
Unfortunately, we can't get teleport working because it's
it relies on the BGP advertisement
from CubeVip.
And other for CubeVip to run, I need
to start the CubeVip. If I start the
CubeVip, things are gonna break through.
I didn't know CubeVip between BGP.
Yes.
I actually I I really need to make
sure Teleport runs on the
bare metal IP instead of the BGP. That's
just a risky mistake by me. So
So to induce the crash loop for Cillium,
I since Cillium one ten, I enabled
BGP in Cilium.
Okay.
So I'm not sure what BPF rules that
might have installed.
I don't know what to do.
I don't I don't either.
I think, let's see.
Well, I can't well, I can't get back
on to Teleport. Yeah. So So, I mean,
I can start the Kubelet, which will get
Teleport
running. But the minute Cillium
comes back up, it's potentially gonna remove all
networking. Is that right?
Oh.
No. Let's just do it because we don't
have any other options right now. Yeah.
Because if Celium's configured,
we need that CD to run anyway
to be able to fix that.
Rachel, I sent you the public IP of
the host so you could SSH if you
wanted.
Ah, okay. That's sweet. Both your keys aren't
on all devices.
Okay. Yeah. I'm gonna avoid a QVDM
reset.
I mean, I guess we could walk through
a QVDM reset, couldn't we?
But then we'd have to bring all the
other notes online,
redeploy the workload.
That's what I've done by now. I'm just
like,
let's just redeploy everything.
Forget
fixing it. I'm gonna do
Yeah. Let's just run many cubes. Screw it.
That's easier.
You
know, this is why we got our, you
know, the point I just gotta leave the
ping running Minutes. And see what happens here.
And
it's a
you get paid, like, extra to to, like,
really break stuff.
Like,
I Oh, I Like, is this something you
really see
customers?
So I tend to call it chaos engineering,
and my manager before has told me, in
order to be chaos engineering, I have to
know what I'm doing.
Mhmm.
Okay.
Okay. You have been has been up for
thirty four seconds, so it should be
hopefully, it began to advertise that address and
get us back onto Teleport
Make sure it's not crashing. Okay.
Click that one.
According
to
the staff console,
BGP looks up.
That is the other one.
Oh, yeah. It's the twenty first start log.
Okay. That is the other one.
Yeah. This is today's
it started advertising.
We should
at the very oh, no. There we go.
Restart teleport.
Okay.
Do we have teleport?
Not yet.
Okay. That's broken now.
Technically, I wasn't the one who broke Teleport
this time.
I can't speak to you.
Restart it.
Okay. Teleport is up.
Yeah. Alright. I'll
have to wait for you to start the
session again.
Okay. We have a new session.
Alright. Let me jump back in. And we
haven't lost networking yet. So we actually might
be in the clear.
K.
It's actually a really good point.
You're
not allowed to SSH and run an info.
So you
might wanna check Etsy host.
Hey, David. I can't I'm,
I'm not in that session. It's not I
don't see this active for me. Hold on.
Oh, forgot. Never mind. Hold on. Need to
sign in.
Ah, okay. Cool.
I'm, like, looking at my session. Like,
you can continue since we're closing on time
here.
Alright. Well,
our and are
trying to pull down our image. It's failing
to resolve it for the TLS error, but
we do still have networking.
So do you remember when I said I
wanted to man in the middle DNS?
Yes.
How can I do that on the local
host?
You could just modify.
Okay.
So that should hopefully fill our API server
image.
Oh, good. I think you just joined the
session there. Right?
Yep.
Have one. My screen looks a little wonky.
Maybe you Yeah. Just give it a wee
reset.
So while you were joining,
we opened the host file and seen that
Andy was pointing kates.gcr.i0
to our local machine.
There we go. Yeah.
Let me just k.
Restart the coupon. Oh, no. Restart.
Restart everything again. I don't know.
Let's
Look at that. We finally have an API
server.
Yay.
Alright.
Do you wanna try and get pods, get
nodes, and actually see if we get a
response from this
stupid cluster?
There we go. Okay.
Alright.
Do you want to try updating our clustered
deployment to v two?
I was gonna just see if it's actually
running
on the application. Do you wanna or you
could show if it check it. Oh, okay.
That's a good idea.
Before I change anything there. Nope.
Internal
server here. Okay.
That's where I think I saw
no. That's two days ago.
Let's see. Yeah. Did
did you do anything else, Andy?
Or can I just work in the manifest
now?
This Yeah. I think I think we can
just work with hopefully, with Kubernetes
API now.
Hey. David,
could you do me a favor? I put
a copy of the cube cuddle back on
there in the root home directory.
Could you, like, a k the cube cuddle
so dot slash cube cuddle, get pods dash
capital a so people could see the fun
I had put in there?
Is this the broken one? Yes.
Nice. Very nice.
And then you still got the honk in
there? I see it.
Okay.
You felt like a Mary.
It's hurting my eyes a little bit, but
Yeah. That's that's sad.
I'm like, what am I looking at? Okay.
So we We
don't have any core DNS. I think that's
why our application isn't working.
Oh, unknown. There we go. Alright.
Let's
see. Where do you have?
Let's see. Yeah. I mean, we're just
wait. Did you do all all
pods and all the namespaces?
Everything. Oh, wait. Get.
Okay.
Replacement.
Our DNS
our
deployment, let's look at that.
I don't think I've ever seen status unknown
before.
Yeah.
It's a
and there's our
daemon set here. Got nothing there.
DNS.
Pods.
Okay.
I'm gonna take a
Go ahead. You go?
No. I'm just gonna take a look here
and here really quickly. See
what's going on. I So
a hint as we're butting up closer. I
don't know if you remember,
but when I was looking at Rachel's cluster,
noticed pods weren't
deploying,
and I looked at the net the CNI
first.
Okay.
So
I guess you're telling me to look
in the c and I first.
Is that what you're telling me? No. Okay.
Okay.
So I mean, we already know he enabled
BGP in the Cilium config.
K. Where is Cilium
config, though?
Where is that? I
think there's a config mapping cube system.
Okay.
This one here? Yeah. I think that's the
one.
We would probably wanna edit that and take
a look for that BGP thing, disable it,
and then do a
do a rollout of the cilium
part,
I think.
Where will it be?
I can't see. Where is it disabled?
You might just wanna search for BGP. I'm
not entirely sure of what what lives in
this project.
That's the only one.
Yeah.
So he said we need build rate.
So we gotta put it in true? I
forgot what you're saying. I don't think we
wanna put that.
Let's
see what else we've got.
Okay. Post your name.
Okay. I'm gonna I'm gonna have to cheat
and look at my cluster because I didn't
touch these things. So I just wanna take
a look
at it really quickly, see what's the difference.
Just taking a
quick look here.
So
it looks like you added something
to
Oh, did you turn off I p v
six masquerade?
Because you should.
IP
what'd you say? Sorry. Miss Andy, what'd you
say? The last part?
That should that
was true. Right? No.
Oh,
whoops.
Should I p v four masquerade be true?
Oh, yes.
I'll just pretend I know what those settings
are, but I have no idea.
I p v I'm pretty sure I p
v six shouldn't be disabled shouldn't be enabled
either. I don't think I put that enabled.
In this one in mine, it's
oh, your screen should let me look at
my screen.
One of one of them I p v
six is false on my
untouched,
version. Let's see. Alright. I've copied that. What
about I p v four masquerade?
Is that true or false? That is true.
And then I p v six masquerade is
true online.
And
let's see. Enable
policy
default remote.
What identity
oh, so those look good to me.
Oh, wait a minute. Disabled TLS
is
where is it? Sorry.
Oh, I typed it while you were at
it.
That is
false online.
Well, it's just Hubble stuff. I think we
can ignore the Hubble.
Okay. Everything else looks
I mean,
let's jump out of this for a second.
Right? Because Okay.
We have
two running operators.
We've got one unhealthy, which I'm assuming this
is this node.
Let's put a log.
See if we can see anything.
Too noisy.
But we could just try and
roll out restart.
You're labeled here?
I would do, d s slash Cilium. You
can tell it's due to Dave and Seth,
that's named Cilium
instead of by label.
Let's see if that helps. I have no
idea. Okay.
But we definitely need one of those silly
and pause to be running.
I mean, let's see. So
while this comes up, could you run that
for my binary? Because there was another Easter
egg in there based off how you ran
that.
It's not gonna actually do anything. Alright?
No.
Was that your Easter egg?
Yeah.
So that when you would try to look
for stuff in the cube system,
it wouldn't find it. But if you actually
take the space out of the between the
dash end argument, it will work.
Alright.
It looks like we have some work in
Cilium,
which I'm happy with. Next problem is we
got broken core DNS, which might just need
a restart.
Okay.
Wrong argument, Karen, or unexpected lane.
Thanks.
Okay.
Did you break core DNS too?
What?
Did I continue my DNS malicious activity?
I don't know. Did I?
You're still not invited back.
So
This
is our core DNS config,
which, again, I have no idea what is
actually supposed to be in here.
But I don't
see anything.
That gives me concern.
Is it
for me?
Ready? Is
that
IPE six
supposed to be doing anything? Or
I thought.
Is it I'm guessing.
I think this is okay because this is
saying Kubernetes plug in.
This is the cluster DNS name, cluster dot
local.
Mhmm.
So which mean
if he's not modified that, he's modified this.
Noise.
Think the image looks good. Yeah. It does.
Is it supposed to be UDP protocol
for one of them?
Yeah. I think that's right. Yeah. Okay. I
think
So the error message was complaining about
oh, I'm scatterbrained
today. It's complaining about the resolve.com.
But
I don't see that mounted.
I
didn't change the Kubernetes deployment.
Right. Well, why am I wasting my time
with you?
So
I
mean, it just uses the host. Right?
Does it?
Does Q just put the host in the
container?
I think it said check that the command
are pretty messy. Unless it's using the system
d resolver.
So on a bunch of 20 o four,
the system d resolver is actually an act
it's not exactly a sibling, but system d
is what writes the at c resolve d
comp. I did not change that.
So null is saying check the Kubelet config
file and see which DNS and
resolve comp file it's using?
Yep. We can do that.
Let's see.
I was using the system d resolver.
I
guess we should look in that file.
My system be Yes. It is.
The same as Same as. Special result. Yeah.
But how does the
that that's all host level settings.
How does the container have DNS?
By magic?
I don't know.
Oh.
What a oh.
I mean, can we get EsterPod?
Let's let's try that. I don't think I
think it's a, isn't it, though? Also,
I would double check the the core DNS
config map.
Okay.
I'd
compare it to another one on that forward
line.
Do you have a a healthy one there,
Rachel? Yeah.
Let me look at mine.
Kubernetes,
let's plug in.
What's your dot local?
Is that
I mean, what's this? Maybe it is that
other than
Okay.
Let me look at yours. Let's see where
we at. Okay. So
fall through
TLS. So I got
minus
core
errors lambda.
I
gotta put it side by side here.
Last time someone modified this config map, they
gave me a unique look alike new character,
yeah, that. And then
the next line, one line.
Yeah. Let me just I'll copy and paste
it here.
Well, that's
let's see. I I'd say that looks better.
But it's just We should run.
Right. So in DNS part so in DNS,
that would say send everything through the resolve
conf.
Right? Because of how the canonical naming works
from
subdomain
to TDL
to or subdomain to domain to d TDL,
the dot indicates seven is everything
through that.
But that's just how core DNS handles the
DNS request out of the cluster for forwarding
connections.
So the max connection is an extra parameter
you don't need.
I would save that. Alright. Let's save our
doc.
Okay.
Oh, I think we're both trying to save.
Oh,
I'm not touching it.
Now you could do a rollout of the
deployment.
Oh, that's so fun.
No, Russell. The unique hot break was not
awesome.
So not awesome.
That guy, actually he's from Glasgow as well.
He's like, is that really the right thing?
And I'm looking at it side by side
with a working core DNS contact and I'm
like, yeah.
Unicode.
Yay. Support DNS. That
okay.
Let's you wanna just take one more look
and see if anything works there?
No? It's trying.
Wait. Did we look at any wait. Was
there others oh, come on.
Oh, failed to connect the database.
But now our
postgres service
may have not have any endpoints?
No. You have endpoints. Maybe
we just have to roll out our cluster
deployment
to get the new Sleep.
Return. Resolve config or something. Okay.
Looks I mean, what did you let's see.
So let's
oops.
Oh, wait a minute. Is it fur it's
frozen for me?
Hold on. I think we can just do
a
Okay. No. It was just stuck. My screen
got stuck. Okay.
Come on. Give me one.
We'll just ignore that one. It's been terminating
for two days.
I still haven't seen that movie, actually.
You've not seen that? That's good.
No. No. So what what what's the error
what's the last What's the end of that
error telling you? Temperature failure and name resolution.
What controls name resolution in the container?
Thanks. So
can you go into the Docker container? Can
you exec into that pod?
Maybe.
So if you do deploy slash
yeah. You don't have to anyway.
Okay.
The vein saying net pool. What's this?
Oh, ping won't work.
Other
reasons. Yeah. Service IP. Because
right.
Which actually during this week's hackathon, we wrote
a demo set to fix that.
So do we have we don't have I
I don't wanna have to remember the name
of the package to install dig. Do we
have DNS resolution? No. No?
Well, what's the what's the IP address for
DNS in the cluster?
10096.
What's the name server that that one's using?
Yeah.
Let's just get services.
And 8 to 60. Oh, yeah. 32.
So what puts that 32 in there?
Nope. Did you not modify the deployment?
Not at all.
The daemon do we have a daemon set?
What
actually creates the container?
Container d?
And who and who provides the instructions for
that? Kubelet. Have you modified the Kubelet config
to pass it a different DNS resolver?
I don't know. Have I? Alright.
Sorry,
RJ. You could type.
Are we going to the
I have tomatoes for throwing, by the way.
I see if this wasn't virtual.
It's throwing away. The
Kubelet config is not in Etsy. Yes. And
the viral load Kubelet.
Let's see. So
yeah.
Var
what is it? Var what? Lip
slash Kuplet.
Lip or Lip? L I b.
L I b. Oh, library. Okay.
It's just my funny accent. Okay.
And then what was it at? Kubelet.
And then there should be a config dot
yaml.
That's the DNS is fine.
So he could be overriding it.
There's two other hosts in the cluster,
and the core DNS doesn't run on the
master. I
always make that mistake when I'm debugging this
and don't jump onto the workers. I get
too comfortable in a control plane.
So we get it. Alright. Do you wanna
pick one each?
I'll grab worker one, you grab worker two.
We'll check the cubic config.
Alright.
Sounds like a good idea to me.
Grab worker two.
Alright. But, hopefully,
you have better luck than I do again
onto that.
Let me see.
What? Okay. That's not expected.
Uh-huh.
And enough of your games.
Did I do something wrong?
I don't think so.
Can you try to touch a file? No.
I can't touch a file.
Oh,
okay. I don't think I did that,
which this makes us really exciting
because this is what I wanted to do
all along.
You have given me a read only root
fail system.
This happened on its own, I swear. I'm
so happy.
I was forcing this to happen, but I
recovered it every time because that broke Teleport.
But it seems like the nonsense I pulled
has actually caused a file error.
How did I change the option? So I
can't remember how to remount or rewrite. I
thought it was dash O Equals.
No. So dash o
remount comma
r w,
and then you need to
and then you need to provide the device.
So it goes device then mount point. MD
one twenty six. What are they? MD one
two six.
Yeah.
It's write protected.
I didn't do this,
but I'm so happy because this induces the
original error I wanted.
I'm getting home.
Do you know how to fix this, Andy?
Let me try something. I know we've put
in another machine.
But it would explain why I couldn't teleport
onto the session.
Right. Because teleport does that audit log, which
writes a file.
Dash t x four
label
equals root.
Hey, David. Real quickly. Worker
too.
Could
you change the cluster DNS
I guess, deleted.
You have to restart Keyblade also.
Oh,
do not see what you changed this year.
Was it '96 or '98?
'90 '6. '90 '6.
Oh, I know what to do.
Yeah. +1 096010.
That should be okay there. Okay. Okay.
On worker one, do FS check dot x
four.
Yep.
It should be the the device.
Alright. Now try to reboot.
Oh.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
K. That one's dead. But Rawkode two is
okay, so let's just get our Rawkode running
there.
Yeah.
You could quarter in that note off.
I could set up on fire.
If
you actually look at dMessage, you can see
where I forced it to mount as read
only, and then it did it on its
own a couple thousand seconds later.
Okay.
Worker one is corded. Rachel, fix the Kubla
configuration,
restarted the Kubla.
Yep.
Alright.
I think can correct.
Which means we should now be in a
position
Where
oh, that might work.
You need the pod to restart so that
it picks up.
Otherwise, Keyblade won't change the
resolve comp.
Yeah.
So if you try now because if those
are in terminating state, they're not in the
pool.
Alright. We have video one.
Okay. So Alright. Let's add our deploy. Okay.
There's only one deploy.
And
let's see.
I'm gonna need a change in career.
I think farming looks nice and simple.
It's just two. Right? David, something else in
there? Or maybe a flower arranger.
That would be quite peaceful.
Okay.
Nine seconds. Now it's over.
I think I still have the watch, but
I think that's just because my browser cache
even
though I'm telling it to do a hard
refresh.
There we go.
There we go. Is that it?
Well, that was painful.
When network stopped working, I stopped trying to,
like, write the steps to fix my cluster.
So,
yeah, that well done. I wasn't sure if
that was recoverable because what I was worried
is that when I restarted the API server,
my malicious one deleted the node from etcd.
I thought I had corrupted etcd,
which is another thing I know you hate
people doing.
Can't stand it.
Because whenever it goes to networking,
or
NCD,
like, all the tooling and experience I've got
is now useless,
and that's the challenge. But at the same
time, it's episodes like this where although it's
a bit of a challenge,
is it you learn all these new little
tools and techniques and other things. And that's
what's important.
Yeah. I mean, I don't think I'll be
having a beer with Andy anytime in the
next couple of years, but
I'm just joking. That
was that was a tough break.
But Yeah.
You made us work for that one. Thank
you. Thanks,
Andy. I learned a lot. That was cool.
I might have to physically break your cluster
next time I see you in person. I'm
just gonna put the hammer, like but
it was cool. Learned a lot on that
one. Yeah. Yeah. No. Your break I think
a lot of people
like myself look at the old episode and
go, oh, how can I be more creative?
And I like the simplicity in yours because
it's like, how well do you know your
Kubernetes? Can you just go through,
like, the from pod creation to service creation
to ingress creation?
Make sure it's all wired up because it's
a lot as like you said, it's a
lot of things developers that I work with
internally need help with just because, like, there
are moving parts and Kubernetes forces you into
a certain deployment model. And so if you
don't remember what that deployment model is, it's
really easy to
forget it. So I think I just have
lots of experience kind of going through those
primitives.
Yeah. I think it's two breaks from different
perspectives. Mine was a developer break. Yours is
more like on the platform
engineer
break.
So we got, like, breaks on both from
both perspectives.
Yeah.
Very well done, both of you. It was
a absolute pleasure working through these clusters. So
thank you for taking time, And if you're
weak for breaking them, joining me and sharing
your knowledge.
I also wanna thank Teleport for sponsoring the
show. Please check out Rawkode.liveteleport
to support the show.
I am gonna go and lie down for
a bit, but again,
thank you, everyone. Thank you for watching. The
cluster will be back next week. Have a
wonderful weekend. Bye.